Ralph you all is the 16 year old who
went to the wrong door and almost paid
for it with his life he'd been sent to
pick up his two younger brothers and
mistakenly went to this house home of 84
year old Andrew Lester
according to police documents he says he
thought Ralph was breaking in when he
answered the doorbell immediately he
fired a handgun through a glass door
Ralph was shot in the head he told
police that when he fell he was hit a
second time in his arm he ran to
neighbors and received help
not before one told him to lie down with
his hands in the air according to a
family lawyer
[Applause]
there had been protests after the man
who fired the shot was released after
less than two hours of police
questioning he's since been charged with
two crimes including assault
prosecutors speak up a racial component
to the shooting
Ralph hadn't gone to 115th Terrace where
his brothers were in Kansas City he went
to an address at 115th Street around the
corner it was a near fatal mistake
he went and rang the doorbell and he was
supposed to stay outside and his
brothers were supposed to run outside
get in the car and they and they come
home and that was what was supposed to
happen and while he was standing there
his brothers didn't run outside but he
got a couple of bullets in his body
instead of a couple of twins coming up
out and giving him a hug and the case
has turned heads in Hollywood actor
Halle Berry shared a thread on Twitter
saying she was sick and tired of this
feeling and that her heart completely
broke when she heard the news
Viola Davis posted a series of pictures
on her Instagram feed and called for
charges to be brought against the man
who fired the gun
the incident May test Missouri's
so-called stand your ground law which
allows for deadly force in response to a
serious threat
a serious question would surround the
threat paused by a boy picking up his
brothers James Matthews Sky News in
Washington